hello and welcome to another episode of
footnotes as per the usual I'm here to
recap the most ravishing ideas from
around wired first up today the Pied
Piper a distant relative of Paula Dean
who endangered children not with wildly
unhealthy recipes but by leading them
into a cave which is far less lucrative
this legendary figure came up in a piece
in our march issue about the effects of
cold environments on weight loss in
reality the Pied Piper has nothing to do
with pies hide simply means he wore two
or more colors which is so last season
legend goes that in the 13th century the
German town of Hameln hired the piper to
lure rats out of the city but then
refused to pay him probably because they
have been watching too much Project
Runway we don't get that and get that we
don't get that at all so unfortunately
my time is done the Pied Piper swore
revenge and eventually returned to lure
the town's children into the countryside
they would never be seen again much to
the relief of at least a few parents who
secretly hated their children it's only
a legend but historians believe that
Hamlin might have actually won slots as
children to plague natural disaster for
a time-traveling Paula Deen whatever the
case the story lives on today in the
phrase pay the piper which you've
probably seen while shopping online next
up nebulous clouds of gas and dust that
sometimes look like horses heads or
cat's eyes or Badgers spleens I guess
wired science put up a fantastic gallery
at least formations rendered in 3d gifts
which appear to be shaking their heads
in disapproval maybe because we told
Pluto it couldn't be a planet anymore so
nebulas actually form a couple of
different ways the most dramatic of
which being the result of a supernova
according to Oasis a supernova happens
when I star drinks too much champagne
and explodes littering the universe with
British accents and eyebrows a supernova
is in fact an exploding star but it
actually dies from pumping too much iron
because it forgot to stretch first you
see star
form elements by smashing simple ones
like hydrogen and helium and to
progressively more complicated varieties
but once they produce iron in their
cores they erupt into supernovas this
populates the cosmos with the elements
so every atom in your body was in fact
born in a star which means Ziggy
Stardust was not so special after all
except for the hair the remnant of this
massive explosion is a cloud of gas and
dust such as the famous crab nebula
which was so bright when it appeared in
1054 ad that people rushed outside to
see it without putting pants on which is
so that season